bonsoir cinquième et dernier débat sur
tvfils 78 à quelques jours du premier
tour de ces élections départementales
2015 nous irons voté dimanche 22 mars et
en plateau aujourd'hui elle est
candidate qui se présente sur le canton
de Montigny le bretonne j'accueille tout
d'abord François de Lignier candidat
socialiste maire de Guyancourt
conseiller départemental sortant face à
lui Michel Laugier candidat à divers
droites soutenu par le Centre par l'UMP
par l'UDA par le modem également maire
de Montigny-le-Bretonneux et président
de la communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin est-ce Sylvain Grison du
Front national candidat donc sur
Montigny-le-Bretonneux conseiller
municipal d'opposition à
Montigny-bretonneux et Émilie Germain
Vedène bonsoir à tous les quatre Émilie
Germain vödrem candidate de la liste
Front de Gauche Europe Écologie Les
Verts sur ce canton conseiller en
municipal à Guyancourt et je vais
préciser bien évidemment que vous
représentez des binômes ce soir puisque
François Deligny est associé à Sandrine
grandgom responsable départemental du PS
Michel Laugier à Laurence trot je suis
conseillère municipale d'opposition à
Guyancourt Sylvain Grison à Eugénie
Lavigne et Émilie Germain donc à Olivier
pareja elle conseille municipal Europe
Écologie à Guyancourt également ce sera
d'ailleurs le thème de ma première
question que pensez-vous de la mise en
place de ces binômes pour le scrutin
départemental une femme et un homme qui
vont sier pour cette nouvelle mandature
on va commencer avec François de Lignier
tout d'abord et je précise bien
évidemment que le temps de parole comme
leur des autres débats sera chronométré
je vous le communiquerai régulièrement
il s'affichera à l'antenne François
deligner sur l'idée d'une d'une parité
et de la mise en place d'un binôme
bonsoir pour cette nouvelle élection il
y a finalement deux nouveautés deux
avancées il y a la parité il faut bien
connaître que c'était plus que
nécessaire au conseil général quand je
siégé nous sommes 39 et il y a six
femmes donc on était très loin de d'une
parité et le nouveau parle pas d'Elvis
président puisqu'il n'y avait pas de
femmes du tout pareil pour la commission
permanente et donc c'est une première
avancée la parité c'est évident la
deuxième avancée également c'est que
maintenant il y a une égalité entre les
cantons
pendant 7 ans quand je votais au conseil
général je représentais plus de 60000
habitants alors que en moyenne c'était
la moitié il y a même des cantons où
c'était le tiers du nombre d'électeurs
donc c'était pas équitable je dois
représenter le même nombre d'habitants
que pour les autres et au moins c'est
une avancée il y a la parité d'une part
et l'égalité d'autre part donc cette
réforme va dans le bon sens c'est ce que
vous nous dites les changements qui sont
opérés sur ce scrutin Michel Laugier sur
la parité tout d'abord sur la parité je
suis tout à fait favorable aussi à la
parité à l'entrée des rentré des femmes
et jours ça aurait pu se faire avant
puisque quand même différents
gouvernements se sont succédés et
personne n'avait aux affaires jusqu'à
présent donc l'entrée des femmes c'est
une bonne chose après le redécoupage des
cantons nous nous c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui dans ce canton de change pas
parce que c'était déjà un débutant les
plus importants de France donc d'où ils
ne changent pas par contre il faut dire
aussi que il y a quand même certains
découpages qui sont complètement
aberrants sur le département des
Yvelines vous citez par exemple vous
avez par exemple vous avez les villes de
Noisy et de Bailly qui sont qui vivent
qui vivent ensemble noisy aujourd'hui et
et avec molle avec Aubergenville et
Bailly qui est juste à côté surtout avec
Le Chesnay La Celle-Saint-Cloud voilà je
dirais il y a certains découpages qui ne
tiennent pas la route pour le Front
national sur la question de la parité
tout d'abord et puis peut-être aussi si
vous voulez sur le redécoupage
effectivement il y avait 39 cantons
avant il y en a 21 maintenant sur la
parité je vais dire comme
Monsieur Laugier et Monsieur Deligné je
dirais je ne peux être que pour
c'est effectivement un rééquilibrage
politique qui s'effectue toutes les
assemblées aujourd'hui seront à parité
donc il n'y avait aucun problème pour
que le département le soit également par
contre sur le redécoupage effectivement
comme le souligner Michel Laugier qui
aurait beaucoup beaucoup par dire parce
qu'il y a des déséquilibres qui sont
quand même flagrants peut-être
équilibrage comme on nous l'a dit
longuement expliqué d'un point de vue de
la population puisque effectivement
c'est un point quand même important mais
il y a quand même des cantons qui sont
assez assez surprenant en termes de
superficie en tous les cas donc même si
la population à un rôle important à
jouer et ça n'en doute pas de faire
faire parfois énormément de kilomètres
aux différents représentants politiques
que de quelques banques qu'il soit
c'est quand même assez assez surprenant
faudrait sur la question de la parité
vous êtes la seule femme au plateau ce
soir
mais ça s'est confirmé parce qu'on
arrive à au terme de ces débats sur les
cinq débats sont plus souvent les hommes
qui sont venus que les femmes d'ailleurs
je parlerai avec la voix aussi de
Sandrine Gangan pour la proposition
comme pour tous les autres candidats
mais je représente je précise
qu'effectivement il a fallu faire pas le
choix et c'est nous qui avons fixé les
règles donc j'en suis j'en suis bien
conscient et c'est ce recommandation du
CSA je le précise pour ceux qui se
poseraient la question parce que vous
imaginez bien que 8 15 20 personnes à
débattre ça deviendrait vite compliqué
donc voilà mais ceci dit plus souvent ce
sont les hommes qui sont venus malgré
tout oui donc c'est quand même très
intéressant que ce soit effectivement
davantage les hommes qui viennent sur
les plateaux sur la question de la
parité c'est intéressant de constater
que tout le monde est d'accord mais il a
quand même fallu attendre une loi pour
que elle soit effective un chiffre 13,8%
c'était le nombre de femmes qui étaient
élus à l'échelle nationale dans les
différents conseils départementaux on va
les appeler comme ça maintenant et il a
donc fallu attendre qu'il est vraiment
une contrainte pour que en soit à parité
égale le problème c'est que cette loi
contraint à se présenter à deux mais
ensuite il n'y a pas de contraintes sur
les vices présidents il n'y a pas non
plus de contraintes sur les présidents
et c'est là que ce sera intéressant de
voir finalement que très certainement
les mécanismes habituels tout comme en
plateau vont probablement reprendre le
dessus je souhaite aussi donc
véritablement sur le fait que les femmes
vont c'est certain apporter beaucoup
d'expertise sur de nombreux sujets
notamment sur la question de la petite
enfance qui va rester dans les
compétences du département et sur
laquelle je souhaiterais vraiment
m'exprimer un petit peu plus tard quand
on viendra sur ces questions-là des
compétences tout à l'heure même si à
l'heure actuelle tout cela est encore en
discussion alors ce qui renforcement la
difficile la mobilisation pour pour les
électeurs vous êtes le conseiller
général conseiller départemental puisque
ce sera le nouveau nom sortant en tout
cas vous leur dites quoi aux électeurs
aujourd'hui venez voter alors que les
compétences ne sont pas clairement
définies parce que c'est encore en
discussion entre les entre les entre les
assemblées entre Sénat et parlementaires
vous leur dites quoi c'est difficile de
mobiliser son terrain je dis surtout et
je le dis aux inimentsins et au
Guyancourtois n'oublions pas surtout que
l'élection départementale c'est une
élection locale
ça veut dire que ça touche véritablement
à la vie quotidienne des familles de nos
communes
on s'occupe des collèges
on s'occupe des logements on s'occupe de
l'éducation on s'occupe des transports
on s'occupe de toute la vie quotidienne
des habitants et donc ne nous trompons
pas d'élection on a bien la possibilité
de voir ce qu'on peut faire tout à
l'heure je parlerai de mon bilan en tant
que conseiller général sortant je ferai
des propositions sur tous ces thèmes le
seul changement apparent ça serait celui
de retirer le développement économique
puisqu'il ira la région mais en fait
nous savons très bien que comme par
exemple département travaille sur
l'aménagement du territoire et c'est
dans ses compétences on est obligé
d'avoir une réflexion en même temps sur
le développement économique et j'ai
plein d'exemples qui montrent qu'au
niveau départemental on peut le faire on
viendra sur la question économique sur
la question du département à un moment
on a parlé de la disparition des
départements aussi et aujourd'hui on
explique qu'il y aura même plus de
conseils départementaux qu'avant parce
que par le jeu des binômes vous serez 42
en tout cas siéger alors que auparavant
vous étiez 39
oui ben c'est le paradoxe du
gouvernement actuel on annonce des
choses et on applique le contraire je me
souviens moi des déclarations du
président de la République de Monsieur
Valls quand il était ministre de
l'Intérieur il était pour la suppression
des départements et à peine de nommer
Premier ministre il est pour la réforme
des départements et j'ai encore entendu
la ministre des collectés territoriales
qui expliquaient que le département
était indispensable aujourd'hui à notre
vie démocratique j'en suis d'accord moi
je t'ai pas je n'étais pas partisan de
la
disparitions
exactement mais c'est pour ça que moi je
suis tout à fait dans la lignée de ma
pensée la seule chose aujourd'hui c'est
que c'est vraiment la première fois
c'est la première fois que nous allons à
une élection nous nous présentons une
élection sans connaître les compétences
qui sont les nôtres demain voilà si
malgré
du fait de d'appeler les électeurs à
aller voter aujourd'hui
il va de soi que nous ne pouvons
effectivement que souhaiter que les
illimontins et l'aiguille courtois se
mobilisent un maximum pour répondre à
notre appel et se présente devant les
urnes dimanche prochain
pour rebondir sur le sur le scrutin il y
a quand même quelque chose qui qui
m'interpellé effectivement nous avons
trois conseillers supplémentaires il y a
personne ici qui pour l'instant on parle
de coup
c'est à peu près aujourd'hui quand on
sait qu'un conseiller général coûte
entre 2600 et 2900 euros
brut je précise par mois ça fait quand
même un budget maxima de
105000 euros
est-ce que on peut se poser la question
est-ce que le gouvernement effectivement
a prévu de budgéter cette somme là
vous êtes conseiller départemental
sortant ça va coûter plus cher
l'assemblée départementale qu'auparavant
je vous rappelle que c'est une élection
locale donc moi ce que j'attends avec
impatience c'est pouvoir parler de mon
bilan puisque j'ai travaillé pendant 7
ans et puis de pouvoir faire des
propositions sur les thèmes qui de toute
façon sont importants je le disais pour
la vie quotidienne et qui resteront au
cœur des départements l'action sociale
restera au coeur des départements c'est
même son cœur de métier au département
mais j'ai parlé aussi des collèges donc
je préférais aller sur le bilan
comme pour les autres
concernant concernant à présent donc je
le disais le fait de voter comme
souligner Michel logier pour la pour la
première fois sans véritablement
connaître les compétences vous allez
lecteur vouloir aujourd'hui votez pour
nous parce que on fera des choses mais
on sait pas encore la question je n'ai
pas effectivement de voter sans
connaître les compétences la question
c'est que moi je représente une liste
qui s'oppose à cette réforme
territoriale pourquoi parce que cette
réforme territoriale nouvelle
organisation territoriale de la
République c'est son nom elle va
finalement aboutir à détruire un système
de proximité c'est à dire à transférer
des compétences on avait parlé
initialement d'un transfert de 14
milliards d'euros en réalité aujourd'hui
on parle d'un transfert de 4 milliards
d'euros vers des structures qui sont
beaucoup plus vastes des structures de
métropoles par exemple à 200 000
habitants et les populations lorsque se
transfert s'effectue et bien il y a une
rupture démocratique ça devient beaucoup
plus difficile d'interpeller non pas son
conseiller départemental mais le
président justement d'un système de
métropole comment le contacter comment
parler de ces difficultés quotidiennes
donc là il y a un premier souci en
termes de démocratie et ensuite
lorsqu'il y a finalement tous ces
rassemblements au nom soit disant de
l'efficience au nom de la solutions des
coûts en réalité c'est des services en
moins si on prend l'exemple de la
Protection Maternelle Infantile il y a
70% des cendres qui sont menacés de
fermeture en langage technocratique on
parle de restructuration mais
restructuration en fait c'est
disparition d'un service de proximité et
quand on est une population fragile
quand on est une jeune maman avec
plusieurs enfants en bas âge se rendre à
20 25 30 40 km pour avoir le même
service que celui qui était autrefois
dans votre quartier et bien voilà c'est
de la dégradation de la vie côté peint
pour les services de la vie quotidienne
c'est ça concrètement et c'est pour ça
que nous combattons cette réforme et pas
tellement si vous voulez la cadence on
est élu avant de connaître les
compétences on va écouter les habitants
de votre canton à présent et vous allez
pouvoir à débattre sur les les
compétences qui devraient en tout cas
rester ou celles qui vont un petit peu
évoluer dans les prochaines années pour
les départements micros-trottoirs
tournés sur le canton de Montigny le
Bretonneux qu'attendez-vous de votre
conseiller de vos conseillers
départementaux
si qu'ils agissent comme un maire dans
une commune comme un chef d'entreprise
c'est-à-dire le développement de la
commune les infrastructures tout ce qui
est lié au bien-être des animaux le
maire par rapport déjà à la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin par
rapport avec ski sans trop croisent en
terme de responsabilité voirie éclairage
public
sécurité et autres alors rajouter une
couche avec les départements c'est plus
qui s'occupe de quoi au niveau de
transport contient ou d'autres on le
sait la situation dit mais que les gens
qui méritent d'aide on va les aider et
ceux qui vraiment ils ont les moyens de
vivre il faut pas qu'il profite aussi du
système Montigny par exemple c'est
Monsieur le Maire qui est aussi
président du l'agglomération c'est très
bien certainement je vais voter pour lui
mais du coup ça fait une multi casquette
ça fait déjà trois casquettes qu'il a et
moi je trouve que ça aussi quelque part
c'est pas très très bien après ce
micro-trottoir on jette un premier coup
d'oeil au chronomètre pour voir de
parole Michel logier et une minute 40
François de Lignier de 07 Sylvain Grison
une 58 et de 53 pour Emilie Germain
vedren on va commencer avec vous Michel
Laugier et ça tombe bien puisque vous
avez été tu peux interpellé dans ce
micro-trottoir multiplication des
casquettes je vous ferai agir aussi
François deligner parce que vous si j'ai
aussi à la communauté d'agglomération de
50 ans en Yvelines vous avez aussi
plusieurs casquettes et au-delà des
casquettes c'est surtout elle
accumulation des strates ce millefeuille
commune cantons intercommunalité région
aussi parce que tout cela est bien
nécessaire est-ce qu'on peut jongler un
même homme peut tout faire alors déjà
même un peu tout faire je pense que il y
a eu des précédents à la dette de la
ville nouvelle à l'époque et à la tête
de la commune de Guyancourt et comme
vous le dites si justement
le maire de Guyancourt aussi d'autres
responsabilités dans tout autant que moi
alors ce que veut dire que moi je suis
plus sur la complémentarité parce que en
fait nous traitons des mêmes sujets et
donc il y a une vraie complémentarité
dans les fonctions que aujourd'hui dont
j'ai la responsabilité que ce soit en
termes de maire de Montigny président de
l'agglomération et que ce soit le maire
ou le président il a besoin de
travailler avec le conseil général
puisque il est compétent dans beaucoup
de domaines dont je vois que on gagne
beaucoup plus en efficacité
de remarque la première c'est que les
élus communautaires sont forcément des
élus communaux par nature par définition
deuxième remarque personnellement je ne
suis jamais présenté à une autre
élection que les élections locales qui
concernent Guyancourt et 50 ans en
Yvelines qui est votre binôme siège à la
région actuellement c'est pour vous dire
qu'on peut être très concentré on peut
être très concentré sur le fait de
rester dans un mandat local moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est vraiment le lien avec
les habitants leur prise en compte
l'écoute et le fait de pouvoir répondre
très concrètement et effectivement il
peut y avoir des complémentarités mais
l'important c'est de répondre j'allais
dire dossier par dossier aux besoins des
habitants
c'est le dossier du social compétences
au combien importante surtout en ce
moment et qui restera en tout cas au
département c'est quasiment certain
Sylvain Grison tout de même sur
l’accumulation des strates les
départements les communes en ce qui me
concerne je veux dire je me sens
nettement moins concerné que Monsieur
tout à fait puisque je ne suis élu au
conseil municipal de Montigny et que ça
ne je dirais de ma carte pas énormément
de temps ce n'est qu'un poste de
conseillers municipal donc je suis moi
personnellement complètement disponible
je dirais pour nos concitoyens sur
l'accumulation des différentes
structures tout cela est nécessaire pour
permettre une complémentarité commune
région état département du point de vue
du terrain je pense que c'est
effectivement une complémentarité je
n'en dirai pas de même je dirais pour
des niveaux supérieurs comme la
députation les sénateurs etc là c'est
différent on joue dans un autre registre
et
je suis pas persuadé qu'effectivement on
puisse parler de dans ce cas là de
complémentarité si c'était vrai je pense
que nos députés aujourd'hui seraient
beaucoup plus proche du terrain parce
qu'en fin de compte leur seul objectif
était Ess entiellement d'être élu d'être
député en barre de vous faire réagir
mais peut-être plus brièvement vous
aviez de l'avance sur le temps de parole
si vous souhaitez vous exprimer sur ça
nous on est dans un parti effectivement
une alliance qui est opposée au cumul
des mandats au cumul d'une façon
générale c'est à dire entre les
différentes fonctions mais aussi à la
succession des mandats au nom des
principes de représentativité et puis au
nom si vous voulez aussi d'un
renouvellement démocratique
on le disait tout à l'heure les
compétences sont encore en discussion
néanmoins les départements vont
conserver le bloc social c'est la
gestion notamment de trois allocations
RSA location personnalisée d'autonomie
là pas ou encore la prestation de
compensation du handicap des trois aides
qui représentent souvent plus de la
moitié du budget des départements chaque
année quels sont les propositions à
chacun dans ce domaine François de
Lignier pour rester sur le bloc social
là on est dans le concret on est dans
les on est dans le concret et c'est le
point le plus important puisque c'est la
priorité normalement
l'action sociale c'est à
l'accompagnement de des besoins des
familles notre département est un des
cinq plus riches de France en même temps
dans en action sociale il est 20% en
dessous de la moyenne des
accompagnements par rapport aux familles
quand je dis par rapport aux familles je
pense aux personnes handicapées je pense
aux personnes dépendantes je pense aussi
à l'accompagnement des personnes âgées
dans leurs besoins mais on pourrait
aussi avec qu'est-ce qui était dit tout
à l'heure sur la protection maternelle
et infantile ou d'autres structures
comme cela un exemple aussi pendant ce
mandala j'ai dû me battre pour arriver à
conserver des postes d'assist social
ce qui prouve d'ailleurs qu'on peut être
dans les positions se faire respecter et
avoir des des résultats et aussi
empêcher des mauvais coups j'ai pu faire
bouger des lignes par exemple on a un
nouveau secteur d'action sociale les
nouveaux bâtiments par contre je suis
obligé encore de rappeler que les postes
doivent être pourvus sur les 9 il y en a
une partie qui n'est pas pourvue des
exemples de ce qu'on peut réussir aussi
nous avons réussi l'implantation d'une
maison médicalisée pour handicapés
psychique c'est très important vous
savez qu'il y a des familles qui sont
obligées d'envoyer des jeunes en
Belgique par manque de place dans le
département donc ça c'est très important
on peut à la fois et c'est ce que j'ai
essayé de faire donner des réponses
concrètes et en même temps moi je suis
vigilant et je dis haut et fort quand ça
ne va pas par exemple pour les PMI il
est vrai que il y a eu beaucoup de
suppression celle de Guyancourt était
conservée parce que je vais la voir mais
je pense que on doit avoir une
répartition territoriale on doit être à
prendre en compte l'ensemble des
familles du département et ce qu'on a
obtenu pour Guyancourt il faudrait
l'obtenir pour d'autres aussi le
département qui ne fait pas assez pour
le social en tout cas mal c'est ce que
dit le Conseil départemental vous savez
on peut toujours dire que on peut faire
mieux s'agir c'est évident et c'est la
et finalement c'est la phrase la plus
facile à dire aujourd'hui le département
a quand même un budget assez conséquent
c'est un milliard 250 000 euros et sur
les 930 millions qu'il y a en
fonctionnement
58%, 58% sont consacrés à l'action
sociale donc 540 millions donc il y a
déjà beaucoup de choses simplement on
demande toujours plus au département
on peut toujours faire mieux on peut
toujours faire mieux je crois qu'il y a
déjà un retour un service qui a porté
aux habitants la chaussure c'est que
pendant ces dernières années le RSA les
les bénéficiaires du RSA malheureusement
le nombre a augmenté donc il y a aussi
beaucoup de choses à financer en
parallèle et qui se sont accélérés au
cours de ces dernières années sans
parler aussi du désengagement de l'État
je vous rappelle quand même parce que
c'est bien beau de on peut faire lisse à
la Prévert tout ce qu'il faut défaire en
plus etc mais comment le financer
comment le financer le Conseil général
va enfin le conseiller départemental
puisque ça sera ça sera sans nouveau nom
va perdre 128 millions de dotations dans
les trois ans qui viennent 128 millions
de dotations alors moi je veux bien
faire vis à la Prévert je crois qu'il
faut surtout savoir bien gérer et le
département des Yvelines a plutôt été
bien géré au cours des dernières années
ce qui lui permet de pouvoir affronter
des périodes plus difficiles avec de
bonnes dispositions sur votre regard sur
le social sur ce qui a été mené jusqu'à
présent par le département dans les
Yvelines et puis peut-être aussi sur vos
propositions que proposez-vous aux
électeurs dans ce domaine-là ce que je
constate c'est qu'effectivement il y a
quand même un budget relativement
conséquent qui est consacré au social
on ne peut que la prouver
je déplore quand même une chose
importante ça j'irai tous les tous les
électeurs qui se tiennent informés en
sont bien au courant je l'espère du
moins s'ils ne sont pas nous le faisons
ce soir
Michel legier vient de souligner les
baisses de dotation sont très
importantes tant au niveau départemental
qu'au niveau des communes
je reviens sur la question que j'ai
posée à laquelle personne n'a répondu ni
monsieur de lignée ni monsieur logier
mais en particulier monsieur de lignée
qui siège au conseil général et comment
financer aujourd'hui les trois
conseillers que l'on aura alors vous
allez me dire que 105000 euros c'est pas
grand-chose par rapport au millions
d'euros que l'on vient d'évoquer mais la
réponse n'a pas été fournie
par exemple avec 10 millions d'euros
dépensés pour la communication de
l'exécutif
parce que vous ciblez directement la
majorité de droite au sein du Conseil
département si on commence à partir sur
ces considérations là j'aimerais qu'on
vienne au social et vous entendre sur le
social je crois qu'il faut déjà balayer
devant sa porte quand je vois l'état du
service de la communication à la
conduite d'agglo je pense pas que la
gauche et le sang a donné à la droite
département et pour resituer les choses
effectivement c'est avant et vous le
savez puisque vous habitez 150 ans en
Yvelines si vous nous suivez la gauche
qui détenait la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin qui est
passé à droite aux dernières municipales
vous souhaitez répondre à ce qui a été
dit François de lignée puisque vous
étiez dans l'ancienne majorité sur
l'agglomération très franchement mais
vous le comprendrez parce que je suis
conseiller sortant et parce que j'ai un
projet en continuité je resterai
concentré sur la réponse aux besoins des
habitants et à chaque fois donc
dites-moi non très simplement dans ces
cas-là et comme ça vous prendra pas de
temps non je ne souhaite pas réagir et
ça ira très vite je peux venir sur le
social donc vous souhaitez réagir aussi
alors allez-y je réagis effectivement
aussi sur ce que dit Monsieur de Lignier
qui veut se concentrer sur les certains
points qu'il a bien mémorisé d'accord
mais il répond toujours pas et ça je
pense et ça même si c'est pas le
président du Conseil du départemental ça
c'est facile si le siège pas dans la
majorité jusqu'à présent les élections
il doit quand même pouvoir détenir des
éléments de réponse qui n'est pas en
capacité d'apporter aux électeurs
aujourd'hui dans un conseil municipal
c'est la loi qui vous oblige aujourd'hui
puisque ça a été fixé ce dont ça a été
un changement janvier de de scrutin on
passe de 39 à 42 donc il va falloir que
les nouveaux conseillers départementaux
soient indemnisées dans le cadre du
budget général du Conseil Général du
Conseil départemental
parce que là ça ressemble un peu à une
fixation je crains que finalement il y
aurait plus d'élus du tout
ça veut dire qu'il y aurait plus de
démocratie donc il y a aussi le prix et
le coût de la démocratie
sur le social les propositions du Front
national aux électeurs
moi il y a une chose qui me tient
particulièrement à cœur alors non pas
que ce soit mon âge j'ai 65 ans j'ai
effectivement des cheveux blancs que
n'ont pas encore ces messieurs et en
tous les cas pas cette dame tant mieux
mais par contre moi ce qui maintient et
qui m'inquiète profondément c'est l'aide
aux personnes âgées je ne vous cacherai
pas je suis confronté directement
aujourd'hui à cette situation là quand
je vois aujourd'hui ce que le Conseil
général au niveau de l'appât est capable
où j'allais dire plutôt même incapable
d'apporter comme aide aux personnes qui
en ont le besoin je suis outré
savez-vous combien aujourd'hui
par jour et le montant de la part pour
une personne
je sais mais je pose la question tout
simplement 8 euros 8 euros vous le
multipliez par le nombre de jours etc
vous arrivez à 240 euros par mois cette
somme là vient en complément de ce que
les gens qui sont en maison de retraite
ou éventuellement à domicile proposition
c'est de relever ces minima c'est clair
c'est de les relever c'est de les
relever aujourd'hui comment voulez-vous
qu'une personne
âgée surtout une personne qui approche
les 80 ans qui souvent en difficulté
physique et psychologique aussi et les
moyens de financer sans sa maison de
retraite c'est impossible nous
interrompre par rapport au temps de
parole puisque vous commencez à prendre
un petit peu d'avance par rapport aux
autres candidats Émile Germain Védrenne
sur le volet social aujourd'hui les
propositions que vous portez pour votre
liste alors sur le volet social on
souhaite effectivement faire des
propositions fortes concernant justement
les personnes âgées le souci aujourd'hui
dans le département c'est l'absence de
structures véritablement public
c'est-à-dire qu'on fait des partenariats
publics privés ces partenariats publics
privés forcément nécessite d'avoir un
entre c'est bon
lesquels il y a forcément une marge et
cette marge elle se fait au détriment
des personnes qui sont dans ces EHPAD
nous ce que l'on souhaiterait proposer
c'est justement des établissements
publics pour accueillir les personnes
âgées c'est aussi de penser autrement
l'accueil des personnes âgées notamment
par exemple avec les maisons
intergénérationnelles ça c'est un projet
qui offrons de gauche à Europe Écologie
Les Verts nous tient à cœur recréer en
fait finalement du lien social parce que
c'est ce qui manque le plus toujours sur
la question du social il y a bien sûr
aussi le problème du logement avec
aujourd'hui le prix au mètre carré dans
l'Île-de-France d'une façon générale les
populations se retrouvent dans des
situations extrêmement contraintes le
département est là aussi pour soutenir
ces personnes en difficulté et nous
souhaitons que le fond social de
logement du département soit abandonnée
abondée soit soutenu et nous voulons
rappeler quand même que sur les 92
communes dans le département qui sont
concernés par la loi et ces rues il y en
a 70 qui déjà n'atteignent pas les 20%
de logements sociaux et ça c'est quelque
chose qui nous semble absolument
scandaleux
de faire remarquer que vous ne faites
pas de liste commune vous êtes d'accord
sur le programme ceci dit on peut avoir
beaucoup de c'est vrai que moi j'ai lu
avec attention en tout cas ceux qui
avaient des programmes parce que je
ferai faire la marque il y a quand même
au moins deux de liste qui n'ont pas de
programme mais sur la question du
logement
il faut partir de l'état des lieux dans
le département des Yvelines pour
atteindre le minimum requis par la loi
des 25% donc il faudrait construire
18000 logements c'est dire le retard
18000 logements sociaux c'est dire le
retard pris dans le département alors
pendant ce mandat j'avais obtenu j'ai
fait partie d'un groupe de travail et
j'ai obtenu des changements de critères
parce que imaginez-vous que le
département aidé en aveugle pour la
construction de logements y compris
c'est la primo mauvais élève parce que
on est des ceux qui n'avaient pas
construit de logement à en faire sans
regarder si c'était du logement social
ou pas
sans chercher à voir l'équilibre de
mixité sociale pour répondre aux besoins
des habitants tels qu'on l'évoquait donc
oui c'est une priorité ce que je
voudrais dire c'est qu'on peut très bien
avoir des aides du département qui soit
avec des critères de mixité sociale
surtout là où il y en a pas et
d'ailleurs on va parler du canton lui en
cours moitié-moitié entre locatif et des
et accession de la propriété et Montigny
se trouve dans une situation où il y
aura nécessité de payer une amende parce
que carence
bien sûr parce que bon c'est très facile
de dire ça en sachant que sur Montigny
bien sûr nous étions à 30% sauf que la
loi essai a changé les critères nous
avions des logements conventionnés qui
ne le sont plus aujourd'hui ça c'est la
première chose et la deuxième chose
c'est que nous avions favorisé
l'accession pour les personnes qui
étaient dans des logements sociaux donc
nous avons vendu aux
occupants ce qui fait que tout de suite
et bien sûr vous avez le tout qui baise
sauf que c'est tu peux rebond fictif
aujourd'hui nous soyons en dessous des
25% puisque nous avons des logements qui
sortent et on les voit très bien donc on
sait très bien que Montigny respecte la
loi sans aucun problème sauf que là on
n'est pas on est dans une compétence du
Conseil Général indirect puisque c'est
uniquement une incitation pour aider
voyez bien c'est pas la compétence
première de construire du logement pour
le pour le Conseil départemental on va
affiche à présent les temps de parole
suff pendant longtemps que je puisse
comme ça les lire si on peut les
afficher à l'écran s'il est temps de
parole sont prêts voilà François denier
vous êtes à 6 minutes 6 minutes 19 et
j'aimerais à 4 minutes 42 Sylvain Grison
550 Michel legier 5 minutes 20 pour
l'autre thématique je vais donc vous
laisser la parole Michel legier puisque
vous accusez le plus de retard vous
souhaitez conclure sur le social allez-y
comme vous avez un peu de retard allez
un petit peu de retard nous avons
énormément de propositions nous
souhaitons souligner la nécessité de
maintenir les maisons départementales
aussi pour les personnes handicapées
c'est un lieu unique où il y a un
accueil pour ces personnes où on va
diagnostiquer où on va aussi les
accompagner on va leur faire des
propositions et ça pour nous c'est
quelque chose de très important
concernant aussi le RSA on souhaite que
les personnes qui reçoivent le RSA
puisse aussi être accompagné vers la
voie de la réinsertion non pas parce
qu'on est dans une logique comptable
mais parce que nous on est dans un
projet d'émancipation humaine et on
souhaite effectivement dire que 514
euros ça ne suffit pas comme horizon
mais c'est ce sont ces 50 14 euros qui
vont permettre effectivement aux
personnes de se réinsérer dans la
société et pour nous il est très
important que tous ces services soient
maintenus comme vous aviez un peu de
retard si vous souhaitez continuer à
agir sur le social sinon on va changer
de thématique
il y a quand même un effort important
qui est fait sur notre canton pour
l'accueil des personnes âgées
sur cuir en cours il y a bien sûr les
certaines résidences dont une en
extension et sur Montigny on aura
bientôt donc un EHPAD ainsi que durant
ce service et là aussi n'est pas dans le
doigt aussi au conseil départemental
merci de faire mon bilan
je pense que le c'est le bilan du
conseil général donc je savais pas que
tu avais une influence aussi importante
je ne sais pas que tu étais président du
conseil général avec une petite remarque
c'est que sur Guyancourt ce sont des
transferts de lit il y a pas eu de
création de lit et donc on a obtenu des
vies qui existait déjà c'est une bonne
chose non mais ce que je dis c'est que
on donne on donne des solutions sur
place voilà quelques soient le disons le
site on est arrivé quand même à
satisfaire d'autres personnes parlons
ce sera justement un partenariat public
privé et ce qui est intéressant c'est le
prix que ça coûtera pour pouvoir en
profiter et ça c'est la question que se
pose les gens c'est à dire on a
effectivement des établissements de type
un petit peu prestigieux on peut
employer ce terme qui peut y avoir accès
alors il y a effectivement un
différentiel qui peut être payé par des
aides du département mais si les coûts
sont importants qui payent la différence
le département et donc on se retrouve
dans un système
où on a des aides qui profitent à des
entreprises privées alors que si on
prenait un véritable service public qui
n'est pas là pour faire des marges mais
pour être au service des populations on
sortirait de ce type de système qui me
semble pas opérant
pour conclure pour ma part sur le social
je soulignerai quand même qu'aujourd'hui
ça n'a pas dû vous échapper il y a une
manifestation dans plusieurs villes de
France et qui est celle des retraités
parce qu'on vient de leur bloquer leur
pension pour 2015 et probablement pour
les prochaines années si on commence à
bloquer les pensions des retraités alors
que ces gens-là pour bon nombre d'entre
eux gagnent moins de 1500 euros par mois
voire pour un certain nombre également
aussi entre 550 et 900 euros par mois je
pense qu'il y a quand même un gros gros
effort à faire aussi à ce niveau là
parce que si on continue à serrer la
ceinture
comment dirais-je les retraités ben ils
n'auront plus qu'à partir à l'étranger
après tout pourquoi pas ils feront
peut-être de la place à d'autres le
temps passe on va continuer à égrainer
les thématiques pour pouvoir parler tout
à l'heure d'économie à la fin de ce
débat compétences économique qui vont
peu à peu disparaître des départements
et vous nous direz quel incidence ça
peut avoir notamment sur le canton je
rappelle que vous êtes présent de la
communauté agglomération de
Saint-Quentin c'est une des compétences
qui doit vous intéresser et les autres
les autres élus qui sont en plateau
également les autres candidats sur la
question des collèges l'éducation les
départements devraient finalement garder
cette compétence des collèges
aujourd'hui sur la question des collèges
est-ce qu'il y a des propositions autour
de l'éducation il me semble que la
droite au niveau départemental évoque
notamment l'installation de tout ce qui
est numérique tablette et autres en se
basant sur l'exemple de ce qui était
développé et en cours écoutez vous avez
déjà donné déjà certaines cercles
ce qu'il faut savoir déjà c'est que la
compétence assurée par le Conseil
départemental de niveau des collèges est
plutôt bien assumé déjà sur notre canton
nous avons six collèges publics mais je
rappellerai aussi à certains qui est
aussi deux collèges privés il faut pas
aussi les oublier ceci et donc je
souhaite que on continue à développer
tout ceci ces choses-là notamment sur le
sur le numérique il y a des travaux
importants qui ont été faits dans nos
différents collèges grâce bien sûr à
l'action du département et j'espère et
j'espère qu'on pourra continuer pour
donner une qualité éducative à nos
enfants qui leur permettra de pouvoir
bien réussir alors c'est vrai que moi
aujourd'hui quand on me parle de
certaines difficultés c'est plutôt dans
les lycées que dans les collèges alors
peut-être que ce serait pas plus mal que
les départements
récupère les lycées qui sont à la région
à l'heure actuelle François de Lignier
très simplement une remarque et une des
propositions concrètes la remarque c'est
que le département des Yvelines dans ce
qu'il apporte pour les collégiens c'est
le plus bas d'Île de France et tous les
chiffres que je donne sont vérifiables
c'est d'ailleurs ma source c'est la
chambre régionale des comptes et
maintenant la proposition elle me semble
urgente elle me semble nécessaire c'est
à cheval sur le social et l'éducation
c'est d'instaurer dans les collèges des
Yvelines le tarif social une
tarification sociale pour la
restauration scolaire de manière à ce
que les plus fragilisées d'un point de
vue économique ne soit pas pénalisé par
rapport à l'éducation quand dans une
famille le problème c'est d'arriver à
faire à manger l'enfant le midi et que
certains sont hors le collège à cause
d'un problème de tarification c'est
dommage et je pense que le département
se grandirait à mettre en place cette
proposition j'ai obtenu l'harmonisation
déjà pour le pour l'avenir je pense que
le tarif social on le fait d'ailleurs au
niveau des communes on pourrait le faire
de manière encore plus simple pour les
collèges et ça serait une nécessité
autour de la gestion des collèges le
Front National qui porte au niveau
national et pas uniquement dans le
département cette proposition de
renforcer les laisser sécurité lutter
contre les raquettes mais en place la
vidéo surveillance écoutez c'est pas moi
qui vais vous dire le contraire surtout
comme ça tout à fait je suis bien
d'accord je l'entends bien c'est notre
programme oui votre programme national
on devrait un programme
c'est tout à fait ce que vous avez dit
et je suis tout à fait d'accord
effectivement il vaut mieux avoir un
programme national que pas de programme
du tout ou tout simplement de la poudre
aux yeux parce que malheureusement
pour revenir au temps
pour revenir aux propositions je disais
que certaines personnes ici autour de la
table connaissent mon passé et durant
une vingtaine d'années j'ai été en
gendarmerie donc j'en suis très fier
même si malheureusement aujourd'hui la
police gendarmerie sont
décrié son lyncher même parfois quand
elle se rendent sur place pour des
interventions donc pour en revenir au
collège effectivement il se passe
tellement de choses à l'intérieur des
collèges mais surtout à l'extérieur des
collèges que il faut effectivement aussi
renforcer la sécurité sur Montigny je
sais qu'il y a déjà énormément de vidéos
surveillance on peut encore aujourd'hui
la déployer auprès des collèges et aux
alentours aux abords et je pense que là
ça serait une bonne démarche que le que
le Conseil général pourrait entreprendre
que ce soit sur le canton de Montigny
comme sur d'autres parce que aller à
l'école avec la peur au ventre j'aurais
aussi des exemples si vous voulez vous
citer mais je ne rentrerai pas de
nouveau dans ce débat
où les enfants
n'osent plus le matin aller à l'école
parce qu'ils se font racketter ils se
font battre la question vous avez des
exemples concrets sur les établissements
qui concernent le canton j'ai surtout un
exemple personnel oui donc je ne citerai
pas je ne demande pas de donner des noms
mais en tout cas il faut quand même pas
sur un ressenti mais sur des faits et
c'est important j'en ai un qui est très
concret en dehors de ce plateau je
pourrais le citer je demandais pas de
donner les noms mais en tout cas de
partir ce qui est lamentable parce que
quand nous avions le même âge que ses
enfants là nous pouvions aller à l'école
sans aucun problème sans aucun problème
donc la priorité autour des collèges
c'est déjà la sécurité
de Montigny sont en vidéo surveillés à
l'intérieur des collèges je mets sur
l'espace qui qui amène jusque au collège
donc surtout les abords nous avons la
vidéo surveillance à Montigny mais
financé par la Ville
sur la question du département et des
collèges alors sur la question du
département et des collèges là je vais
avoir un point de vue très tranché moi
je vais apporter mon expertise en tant
qu'enseignante nous qu'est-ce que nous
proposons nous proposons des
établissements à moins de 500 élèves qui
restent à taille humaine puisque lorsque
justement on est dans des structures
beaucoup trop importantes ces soucis qui
peuvent exister effectivement de
raquettes de mal-être sont difficilement
gérables par les équipes mais qu'est-ce
qui va permettre de gérer ces
difficultés ce n'est pas la vidéo
surveillance c'est l'humain ce sont des
éducateurs ce sont des enseignants ce
sont des assistants vie scolaires la
vidéo surveillance est un échec c'est
une technologie qui aujourd'hui est en
train d'être mise en place effectivement
en France je propose à tous ceux qui
sont autour de ce plateau et à tous ceux
qui nous regardent d'aller consulter les
rapports de Scotland Yard et d'aller
consulter les rapports du FBI pourquoi
parce que ils sont très précis ce sont
les angles Saxons qui les premiers ont
mis en place la vidéo surveillance il
nous montre quoi ça n'évite pas la
violence parce que les personnes pensent
que les caméras ne fonctionnent pas et
3% en moyenne des délits ou crimes sont
résolus grâce à la vidéo surveillance
donc pour moi c'est une impasse
concernant maintenant aussi nos
propositions vis-à-vis de la
restauration scolaire ce que nous
souhaitons mettre en place sont des
circuits courts pour permettre aux
enfants de manger des choses qui sont
produites dans le département et de
manger aussi des aliments de qualité
c'est à dire que dans la nourriture il y
a bien sûr la quantité mais il y a aussi
la qualité et on souhaiterait que ces
produits soient issus d'une agriculture
durable et ça c'est très important si
vous si vous interrogez les enfants qui
vont au collège alors certains ont
peut-être la peur au ventre mais surtout
ils mangent pas beaucoup
faire tour de table très rapidement mais
vous êtes très en avance donc très
brièvement très brièvement madame est
enseignante
critique pas la profession simplement
par rapport non non pas du tout je sais
que Monsieur deligner le temps de parole
passe allez-y parce que vous êtes en
avance vous avez presque une minute
d'avance je j'attire simplement votre
attention que là où les choses se sont
passées il y a aussi des enseignants ils
n'ont rien vu n'ont rien vu il y a des
éducateurs ils n'ont rien vu alors je
pose la question à quoi servent-ils en
dehors de l'enseignement si vous voulez
réagir et Michel leger vous jouer à peu
près et vous serez tous autour de 8
minutes je vais être très court un ne
pas confondre par rapport aux
compétences du département sécurité
publique compétences régaliennes et la
sécurité civile et là pour le
département ce sont les pompiers qui
font un travail que je salue et qui est
un travail aussi au quotidien pour
revenir au collège je crois beaucoup aux
liens entre justement au sein de la
communauté éducative entre les
responsables d'établissements les
équipes enseignantes et les parents
d'élèves les parents d'élèves qui sont
investis font un travail formidable pour
que la communauté éducative soit capable
de mieux maîtriser ce genre de question
et pas le faire dans le fantasme ou dans
la peur mais dans le faire dans
l'éducation c'est logique pour conclure
cette thématique je suis d'accord avec
François de Lignier sur ce qui se passe
à l'intérieur après le vrai problème
demeure quand on est sur les sur les
abords par contre tout à fait dans les
mêmes problèmes sauf que en tant que élu
locaux nous avons aussi la
responsabilité de ce qui se passe aux
abords des des collèges en tout cas moi
je peux vous dire que à travers tous les
c'est les SPD que je que je préside
exactement je peux vous dire que le
préfet le commissaire de de police se
suivent ça de très très près et que
surtout ils sont ils sont là pour nous
encourager à investir dans la vidéo
surveillance parce que pour eux c'est
extrêmement important qui vous fait
sourire oui oui on parle de fait
j'attends de voir effectivement comment
est-ce qu'on lutte contre la délinquance
juvénile avec des caméras
parce qu'on n'aura pas assez de temps
pour toi aborder et vous laissez le
temps à chacun pour vos conclusions je
rappelle on va on va revoir les temps
pendant que je lance la thématique
suivante comme ça chacun pourra bien
voir où il en est sur la question
économique sur la question de l'aide aux
entreprises ce sera désormais la faire
des régions en tout cas c'est ce que
prévoit cette loi notre qui est discuté
actuellement même si toutes les
évolutions sont encore possibles mais en
tout cas la compétence économique qui
pourrait disparaître Michel Laugier je
vous passe la parole en tant que
président déjà de l'agglomération de 50
ans en Yvelines avec un territoire où
l'économie les entreprises sont très
importantes cette compétence qui
échapperait au département ce sera
embêtant oui ça se remet tomber c'est
vrai que c'est dommage d'avoir un débat
sur des choses qui ne sont pas encore
fixées donc parce que là il y a eu déjà
une première lecture à l'Assemblée mais
je pense qu'il va y avoir certaines
navettes et quand on va finir par par
une occuper son mixte paritaire et qui
va définir les choses donc c'est un
petit peu dommage de parler de certaines
compétences alors que on ne sait
toujours pas si on gardera cette
compétence économique ou pas moi je suis
pour la proximité toujours alors c'est
vrai que au niveau de nos villes et de
l'intercommunalité les choses se passent
plutôt bien on est quand même un
territoire très dynamique et on
accueille toujours de nouvelles
entreprises et moi ça me fait ça me fait
plaisir mais j'aurais préféré travailler
avec quelques avec une collectivité
beaucoup plus proche voilà donc que peut
apporter un département justement à une
intercommunalité comme c'est dans les
compléments pardon dans la
complémentarité notamment sur les
transports on peut nous aider aussi sur
les transports sur les routes aussi
parce que c'est aussi de la compétence
du conseil général la vie la vie de
proximité elle ne peut passer que par
l'aide du Conseil général sans parler
aussi de l'aide de que le Conseil
départemental excusez-moi mais bon ce
sera dans quelques jours pour le moment
de toujours dans le conseil général
aujourd'hui toute l'aide qui est
apportée aux collectivités quand on fait
des travaux dans une école à travers les
contrats départementaux on peut quand
même avoir de gros financements donc je
pense que toute cette accompagnement là
que nous avons au niveau de chaque
commune que nous avons au niveau de
notre intercommunalité et bien est
indispensable et c'est vrai que moi je
suis pour la proximité et la proximité
ça veut dire l'efficacité
je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure il y a
plusieurs manières pour le département
d'aider au développement économique vous
savez notre canton fait partie de 50 ans
en Yvelines et tout le travail qui a été
fait pendant de nombreuses années nous a
permis de nous hisser comme deuxième
pôle économique d'Île-de-France donc
nous ce qu'on a besoin au niveau du
département c'est sur des dossiers
communs de travailler à des réalisations
qui correspondent à ce développement on
a besoin par exemple de transport en
commun aussi propre pour qu'il y ait des
meilleurs liens pour les salariés des
entreprises on a besoin aussi parfois de
travaux d'aménagement qui nous
permettent d'accueillir des nouveaux
établissements et à chaque fois ça doit
pouvoir se faire avec le département
quant aux subventions je voudrais
rappeler que pendant ce mandala moi j'ai
regretté que le département donnait en
aveugle sans proximité justement c'est
comme ça qu'on a donné par exemple un
continental qui se délocalisait juste
après
comme ça vous sera à 9 minutes et ce
sera très brièvement sur la question
économique sinon vous n'aurez pas le
temps de la conclusion après pour le
Front national alors sur les questions
économiques nous on souhaite attirer
l'attention des électeurs sur le fait
qu'il est nécessaire de promouvoir une
économie sociale solidaire avec des
emplois justement qui sont non
délocalisables le problème effectivement
c'est que ces subventions très
importantes sont parfois données à des
sociétés qui font des profits et
pourtant délocalisent puisque la loi le
permet et on souhaiterait effectivement
que l'attribution de ces subventions
soit l'objet d'une surveillance
véritablement accrue concernant le
développement économique on souhaiterait
aussi accompagner les sociétés qui
souhaitent effectuer ce virage vers
l'économie sociale et solidaire et
l'économie aussi circulaire cette idée
que les déchets de certains deviennent
la matière première d'autres sociétés et
mettre en place de véritables filières
comme une filière bois par exemple
exemple sur le département on
souhaiterait aussi soutenir les
agriculteurs qui veulent s'engager dans
le cadre à l'échelle effectivement de
l'Union européenne de la réforme de la
PAC vers une agriculture qui passerait
du productivisme vers une agriculture
cette fois-ci de qualité et ils ont
besoin d'un soutien ils ont besoin d'une
écoute ils ont besoin de subvention le
département pourrait être un acteur dans
ce domaine car nous sommes un espace où
les terres agricoles sont importantes
je vais vous laisser une trentaine de
secondes comme ça il vous restera une
trentaine de secondes pour conclure ou
alors si vous souhaitez garder votre
temps de parole pour la conclusion d'une
minute non moi je dirais simplement que
on est dans une coquille vide
aujourd'hui et on ne sait absolument pas
où l'on va en matière économique et
d'une façon générale ce que sera le
Conseil des départementales dans les
prochains mois et dans les prochaines
années
et malgré du fera il faudra voter pardon
nous arrivons à l'issue de ce débat vous
avez chacun à peu près une minute sauf
effectivement Sylvain Grison et émy
Germain vaudrait un petit peu moins une
quarantaine de secondes et Sylvain
ingrédient une trentaine de secondes et
vous serez tous aux alentours de 10
minutes afin de veiller à l'équilibre à
l'égalité les quitter en tout cas à
l'issue de ce débat François Deligné
pour votre conclusion en une minute
en une minute je voudrais dire que
Sandrine grand gambe et moi-même sommes
des élus de terrain
ce qui compte c'est le contact avec les
habitants c'est l'écoute c'est l'échange
en 2008 les habitants de Montigny et de
Guyancourt m'ont élus au conseil général
depuis j'ai travaillé j'ai agi j'ai un
bilan je peux pas évidemment l'expliquer
en une minute mais chez pris soin avec
Sandrine Grandgambe
le présenter et également de faire des
propositions car nous sommes dans un
département où nous pensons que il est
possible d'agir avec des ambitions et
que dans un département trop ancré à
droite il est bon d'avoir des élus qui
portent la voix des habitants sur leurs
besoins tels que j'essaie de l'expliquer
ce soir un dernier mot aussi c'est pour
préciser que nous souhaitons un
département qui soit le plus équilibré
possible il y a trop de déséquilibres
dans ce département et également un
département qui soit solidaire je l'ai
dit le département pourrait concentrer
ses moyens sur les notions de solidarité
merci François de Lignier Michel legier
à présent
socialiste se désengage de collectivité
on a besoin de se rapprocher entre
collectivités et je pense que le
rapprochement avec le Conseil
départemental est indispensable alors je
pense que entre le maire de Montigny que
je suis président de l'agglomération
se rapprochement se fera de bonnes
manières parce que il a il en va de
l'intérêt de nos habitants de Montigny
et de Guyancourt dans ce travail je le
ferai avec Laurence truchu élu municipal
à Guyancourt et je demande tout
simplement aux électeurs qui me font
confiance depuis maintenant très
longtemps et bien de m'accorder à
nouveau cette confiance ils ne seront
pas déçus à présent une trentaine de
secondes pour vous décidément
vous avez le même temps de parole que
tout le monde
le Front national pour nous est une
alternative qui est plus que crédible
face
contrairement à ce que bien évidemment
nos adversaires de l'UMPS viennent
encore se laisser entendre aux électeurs
nous avons les moyens nous avons les
hommes nous avons les femmes quel que
soit le niveau que ce soit au niveau
départemental comme au niveau du canton
bien évidemment donc il n'y a aucun
souci nous sommes prêts je dirais à
rentrer dans ce conseil départemental
dès demain et pour conclure pour votre
liste menée par le Front de gauche et
Europe Écologie Les Verts
et Jeanne nous portons une liste qui
s'appelle autrement autrement parce que
nous voulons proposer justement d'autres
idées nous souhaitons mettre un terme à
la dégradation des services de proximité
la fermeture des PMI la fermeture du
planning familial le démantèlement de la
Bibliothèque départementale nous
appelons les électeurs à voter pour nous
afin de dire non à la dégradation de
l'environnement et ce sera votre dernier
mot puisque vous êtes tous à 9 minutes
55 à 2 secondes près vous êtes tous à
l'égalité merci à tous les quatre d'être
venu pour débattre sur ce canton de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et qui couvre
également la commune de Guyancourt
l'émission sera rediffusée mercredi 18
mars 20H vendredi à 20 mars également à
20h à retrouver sur notre site internet
dès à présent en replay rendez-vous
dimanche n'oubliez pas 19h45 pour la
soirée électorale du premier tour sur
télé-files en simultané sur Radio
sensation très belle soirée